un jouet piégée à l'hôtel de ville par
miracle le mécanisme d'explosion n'a pas
fonctionné 1% c'est la hausse des prix
de mai l'état de santé de l'économie
française
philippe sassier côte bretonne est
insatisfaisant un reportage d'un doublé
ce qui les prêtent hors de l'église de
plus en plus nombreux mais toujours
aussi mal acceptée invité de notre
journal monseigneur badr et messieurs
bonsoir imbéciles dérisoire c'est ce que
nous disions déjà hier à propos de
l'attentât de versailles titre repris ce
matin par la plupart de nos confrères et
j'imagine sans mal les qualificatifs qui
nous serait venu à la bouche si la bombe
du berger avait explosé car figurez-vous
que hier à l'heure où nous parlons du
terrorisme un employé de ce grand
magasin parisien près de l'hôtel de
ville découvrait un engin explosif au
rayon jouets
la bombe d'une machine infernale très
dangereuse était réglée pour exploser
samedi après midi c'est à dire à la
pleine heure de la cloche et je le
répète au rayon jouets dans une boîte de
voitures en modèle réduit pour enfants
par miracle le dispositif n'a pas
fonctionné mais on frémit autre bombe
désamorcée à temps devant un restaurant
du centre de paris rue poterie tout cela
bien sûr fait froid dans le dos parce qu
anonyme lâche et bien gratuit et ce qui
s'est passé à versailles a également
scandalisés tout le monde la cour de
sûreté de l'état s'est saisi de la
procédure criminelle car il semble bien
que des éléments sérieux et permis
d'accréditer la responsabilité d'un
mouvement autonomiste breton dissout la
r d d'ailleurs les policiers de rennes
montpellier ont procédé ce matin à neuf
interpellations dans ces milieux dans
les partenaires d'ille et vilaine au
delà de l'enquète au delà du bilan que
nous faisions hier soir il faut
maintenant se mettre au travail et cela
va être long
combien de temps mettra ton pour
restaurer ce tableau une oeuvre de
dobrée sans doute la plus touchée est
peut-être irrémédiablement un an deux
ans au fond nul ne sait il faudra
d'abord retrouver les morceaux de toile
dans les gravats une longue patience et
puis reconstitués morceau après morceau
le tableau avant de le coller sur une
toile 9
mais pourra-t-on retrouver les mêmes
teintes les mêmes dorures de ce
bonaparte qui semble être découpées au
rasoir
personne n'ose encore se prononcer la
technique c'est les connu est longue et
délicat il faut attendre les toiles
faire des retouches au mastic et les
peindre et puis combien cela
coûtera-t-il certains annoncent le
chiffre de 5 millions de francs mais est
il possible de chiffrer de tel chez nov
je rappelle qu'une souscription
international a été lancé pour la
restauration du château l'adresse
fondation de france contre château de
versailles
ccp paris 3 169 67 rue de lille 75 euros
cette partie dans le même ordre d'idées
un million de francs de récompense et
qui retrouvera les douze tableaux de
maîtres volés il ya une semaine à
marseille et le texte une petite annonce
parue ce matin dans plusieurs journaux
l'auteur la compagnie d'assurance la
lotte mes affaires économiques et
sociales maintenant reprise du travail
pour les neuf mille ouvriers jusqu alors
en chômage technique à flins chez
renault reprise assez confuse car selon
la direction quelques dizaines de
grévistes très agressif ont essayé
d'empêcher au besoin par des menaces le
fonctionnement les opérations quatre
ouvriers qui travaillaient au presse ont
été blessés transportés à l'hôpital
les syndicats des approuve ces violences
et la cgc a décidé de se pourvoir en
justice pour coups et blessures boussac
le mouvement de protestation des
ouvriers du textile dans les usines
vosgienne s'est encore durci ce matin
les barrages se sont multipliés sur les
routes et même sur la voie ferrée ainsi
que sur le canal de l'est
arsenault peut-être un déblocage en tout
cas première rencontre syndicats
ministère de la défense demain et puis
un chiffre celui de l' indice des prix
pour le mois de mai il n'est pas bon
mais moins catastrophique que celui
qu'on avait pu hier encore 1% 1% tout
juste il est dans la ligne des
précédents 0 9% en mars 1,1 pour cent en
avril
l'occasion pour antenne 2 de faire le
point avec philippe sassier ce n'est pas
un peu d'indicés les indices des mois de
juin et juillet ne seront pas bons non
plus ils vont répercuter bien évidemment
la hausse des tarifs publics ce que l'on
peut ajouter c'est que si on ne tient
pas compte de cette hausse des tarifs
publics la hausse des prix au mois de
mai dès que de 0 6%
c'est à dire que les prix industriels et
les prises alimentaires sont pour
l'instant restés très sages mais qu'est
ce que l'on peut lire sur le tableau de
la conjoncture de l'économie française
nos échanges d'ailleurs le commerce
extérieur est bien pour le quatrième
mois consécutif
nous avons davantage vendu qu'acheter à
l'étranger et ceci est un bon point pour
les produits français qui semble-t-il
reste compétitif parce que l'activité a
été très soutenue au cours des premiers
mois de l'année est en général qui dit
activités
et soutenu 10 des importations en hausse
le franc est une des pièces maîtresses
de la politique française puisque qui
dit un franc fort dit pétrole acheter
moins cher et bien depuis la fin du mois
de mars le franc reste extrêmement fort
devant le dollar est devant la presse
les principales devises étrangères
également la consommation la
consommation des ménages a connu un
véritable boom au mois de mai dernier
les français ont acheté pour plus de 16
milliards de francs de produits divers
ils ont acheté par exemple 190 mille
voitures neuves
c'est énorme et puis illégalement une
flambée sur les ventes des téléviseurs
en couleurs sa lune évidemment c'est le
mundial qui a entraîné toutes ses ventes
en revanche il ya toujours une aiguille
qui restent dans le rouge bien celle
aiguilles du chômage l'éguille de
l'emploi à la rentrée monsieur boulin le
ministre du travail prévoit qu'il y aura
environ un million deux cent mille
demandeurs d'emploi en france alors
qu'est ce que l'on peut dire pour cette
rentrée bien si la france a réussi un
assez bon premier semestre 1978 il ya de
certaines craintes pour la rentrée la
consommation peut se ralentir à la suite
du ralentissement dans la progression de
notre pouvoir d'achat
deuxièmement l'activité industrielle qui
a été bonne au cours du début de cette
année là aussi elle peut connaître un
certain coup de frein c'est la raison
pour laquelle la france aimerait bien
qu'à bonne etc à brême surtout dans
quelques jours l'allemagne décide de
soutenir son économie parce que
l'allemagne est en notre premier client
qui dit soutient l'économie allemande y
commande pour la france oui j'ajoute
qu'une nouvelle hausse est prévue pour
le 1er juillet c'est à dire pour samedi
celle des loyers + 6 5 % pour les loyers
réglementés c'est un chiffre qui peut
grimper jusqu'à 11% pour ce que l'on
appelle les loyers de 48 c'est à dire
pour les habitations construites avant
cette date de 1948 en tout cas raymond
barre orapi enregistré le soutien sans
réserve et sans nuance site des clubs
perspectives et réalités à sa politique
économique et sociale les suite de
l'échec de la gauche à aix en provence
tout à l'heure sur france inter gaston
defferre en a rendu les communistes
responsable un sondage de l'ifop pour le
compte des commissions de la commission
des communautés européennes de bruxelles
67% des français sont favorables à
l'élection du parlement européen au
suffrage universel direct
12 % sont contre et c'est précisément
pour préparer ces élections de juin
prochain que se réunissent ce soir à
paris trois partis de droite un espagnol
un étal
la france est le parti des forces
nouvelles jean louis tixier vignancour
qu'il a rallié récemment entend mener la
tête du combat de l'euro droite dans ce
débat électoral tout cela ne plaît pas à
tout le monde en tout cas pas au
mouvement de gauche auxquels se sont
joints la cgt la cfdt et la peine c'est
qu'un certain nombre d'associations
diverses et qui pour protester contre ce
meeting à la mutualité ont organisé
depuis une heure et demie vous voyez une
contre manifestation à l'as dit elle se
dit qu'est ce que l'euro droite
encore un terme nouveau après leur
communisme la réponse de daniel
grandclément daniel grandclément donc
qui se trouve sur place à la mutualité
et qui va nous présenter ce meeting de
leurs droits ce soir à 20h30 pour
l'instant l'euro droite c'est trois
petits partis qui essaye de faire parler
d'eux alors pour l'instant aussi la
réunion de ce soir est un succès la
première preuve c'est qu'elle a lieu le
meeting n'a pas était interdit ensuite
d'une certaine manière les partis de
gauche en manifestant ce soir lors fin
de la publicité le calcul des dirigeants
de cette nouvelle extrême droite
européenne et sam
au plan national il représente peu au
plan européen
ils peuvent espérer faire entendre leur
voix le système électoral à la
proportionnelle favorise les petits
partis
c'est ainsi que de toutes petites
formations comme le pfn peuvent espérer
obtenir quelques députés
pour cela il ya une condition obtenir
plus de 5% des voix ce qui ne sera pas
évident ce qui ne sera pas facile compte
tenu des différentes situations
nationales
msi mouvement social italien c'est le
parti d'extrême droite que tout le monde
d'ailleurs qualifie de néo fasciste le m
et 6 protestent nous ne sommes pas des
nostalgiques de mussolini
d'ailleurs certains jeunes du msi
écoeuré par la respectabilité du parti
on choisit parfois la violence et même
le terrorisme
giorgio almirante 65 ans leader du msi
séduisant cultiver peut-être le seul
homme politique italien capable
d'improviser brillamment combien
sont-ils les adhérents du msi un demi
million paraît-il cela dit le msi est en
perte de vitesse il ya six ans il avait
recueilli 8% des voix 2 millions
d'électeurs
en 1976 le msi tombe à 6 % il perd 21
députés sur 55 places pignard 59 ans qui
s'apprête ici à part les vols de
monseigneur lefebvre un fait l'homme le
plus à droite d'espagne watson wave à
son parti depuis 1976 et c'est la loi
forçant organisation par habiter les
militants des jeunes des hommes et des
femmes souvent modestes qui ont adopté
le salut fasciste
leur devise dieu patrie justice forza
nuova annonce un million de
sympathisants ne compte aucun élu aux
cortès le pfn partie des forces
nouvelles à quatre ans qu'il est formé
d'anciens militants de l'organisation
d'extrême droite ordre nouveau et de
dissidents du front national le parti de
jean-marie le pen
selon ses dirigeants le pfn veut lui
aussi faire oublier les démons
traditionnelles de l'extrême droite
antisémitisme et violence sa principale
stratégie politique
un anticommunisme virulent le pfn
affirme regrouper dix mille militants ou
sympathisants actifs
il a obtenu 1,26 % des suffrages aux
dernières élections législatives
voilà pour l'événement politique de la
journée ou de la soirée l'événement
demain je pense en toute modestie que
cette antenne 2 qu'il créera avec un
carte sur table exceptionnelle à 21h25
jean pierre elkabbach et alain duhamel
recevront jeannette torres vermeersch
est à dire la veuve de l'ancien
secrétaire général du pc elle ne s'est
pas exprimé depuis très longtemps et
vous allez le voir il s'agit je crois
d'un personnage hors du commun sauf
leurs la vie la nuit
et ils ont des gens éveillés alors je
m'imagine qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire elton l'accouchement est ce un
malade elle son insomnie av
est ce que c'est un jeune couple qui a
fait l'amour est qui qui se donne un
beau monde bon temps ses voisins l'ont
surnommée la vieille dame digne
à 68 ans jeannette torres vermeersch
cool en effet des jours tranquilles dans
son appartement d'ivry dans la banlieue
parisienne ses activités cuisine ménage
mais surtout rédaction de ses souvenirs
elle aime relire ses notes de voyage
écrite avec la plume de la militante sur
des cahiers d'écolier persuadé que c'est
l'occident impérialiste qui apporte et
développer ses dépravation favorisée par
une famine l'attend permanente
on parle d'enfants utilisé par les
parents pour inspirer la pitié ah oui il
faut changer le monde c'est autre
journal c'est un journal de voyage que
vous avez journal un voyage ou un voyage
ou à travers le monde et vous êtes très
attaché aux souvenirs au passé à séoul a
ses atouts ses fidèles ces photos par
exemple qu'est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
représente pour vous c'est je suis en
train de lutter comme tous les
communistes comme pas mal de gens en
france pour la peau vietnam vous voyez
imposant la pub d'amener des gens de
retour de corée spéciaux nerfs et je
n'aime parce que quelquefois on peut
douter de ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on dit
et je vois que tous les camarades qui
sont assis au bureau écoutent
attentivement
ils sont intéressés par ce que je dis
c'est un concours temps alors je lance à
personne mais le souvenir pour jeannette
vermeersch c'est surtout ses 34 années
de chemin avec maurice thorez qu'elle
rencontre en 1930 elle va lui donner
trois fils avant de l'épouser en 1947 la
vie de mère de famille complète celle de
la militante inscrits à 18 ans au parti
communiste
elle entre à 40 ans au bureau politique
passionné fougueuse on l'a dit
stalinienne et intransigeante mais
toujours sincère les deux ruptures dans
sa vie seront la mort de maurice thorez
et son départ en 68 du bureau politique
pour divergence avec le parti sur
l'interview
son soviétique à prague depuis dix ans
elle n'est plus qu'une simple adhérente
du parti communiste qui rassemble ses
souvenirs
ça c'est une photo de maurice thorez et
moi dès 1936 voilà mon fils aîné jean
mais derrière ces souvenirs de famille
derrière cette littérature de militante
communiste et se passe et qu'elle
entretient sobrement ce qui frappe c'est
surtout sa foi inébranlable dans l'homme
j'ai deux russes ne recourent
effectivement l'art et lénine et maurice
thorez et là je trouve ce que les hommes
ont laissé dans l'art comme trace de
confiance dans l'homme comme trace de
civilisation
je me dis mon dieu pendant tant de
milliers d'années des hommes ont
souffert peiné travail et créer pour en
arriver nous sommes aujourd'hui ça me
donne confiance incroyable dans l'avenir
voilà donc rendez vous demain soir à
21h25 pour cartes sur table quelques
brèves nouvelles de politique étrangère
d'abord une agression à moscou en plein
centre un forcené a attaqué à la hache
trois touristes suédois deux d'entre eux
sont morts
le jeune homme a été maîtrisé sur les
marches de l'un des plus grands hôtels
de moscou
ce sont finalement les dirigeants pro
soviétique qui l'ont emporté au yémen du
sud et l'ancien chef de l'état a été
fusillé après l'écrasement de la révolte
militaire
pour rappel que samedi c'était le
président du nord qui avait été
assassiné dans un peu plus de cas d'un
quart d'heure maintenant vous avez
rendez vous avec toute l'équipe des
dossiers mais cran et pendant toute la
soirée
antenne de essaiera de faire le point le
plus objectivement possible sur la
catastrophe de l'amoco cadiz on y
parlera beaucoup des causes des
responsables des moyens éviter de
pareilles drame mais avant toute chose
nous avons voulu au journal demandé aux
touristes qui vont bientôt prendre le
chemin des vacances de ne pas déserter
la bretagne
après une enquête approfondie de
plusieurs de nos reporters et en dehors
de toutes considérations affectives
nous pouvons dire que les plages du
finistère nord est de la partie touchée
des prout du nord sont propres à 90% et
qu'on y peut sans déplaisir passer de
bonnes vacances
dans le lointain quelques bateaux au
premier plan on devine le sable blanc à
travers l'eau claire et pourtant nous
sommes à quelques centaines de mètres de
l'épave de l'amoco cadiz à portsall et
puis centre du phénomène marée noire
aujourd'hui pour ça le tristement
célèbre attirent le touriste c'est
presque un pèlerinage ici partaient les
nappes de pétrole qu'elle est englué les
plages sur des kilomètres soyons précis
exactement 300 km sur les 1500 que
compte le littoral breton jamais baie de
saint brieuc quad et broad nie toute la
côte sud n'ont été atteint les 300 km de
côtes touchées de la pointe de brest au
sillon du talbert sont aujourd'hui
propre en grande pas la remettent encore
sur place et poursuivra son effort
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juillet c'est
des travaux de finition restent à
réaliser sur les pointes rocheuses kring
l'estuaire la majorité des plages salle
il y a trois mois sont d'ores et déjà
propre ou acceptable propre les plages
principales acceptable
les autres en tout une soixantaine les
mairies donne des renseignements pris
tout ce travail afin de sauver le
littoral breton mais aussi son économie
basée sur le tourisme et la pêche
que serait le conquet trégastel perros
guirec et bien d'autres sans le tourisme
en semi léthargie l'hiver ces régions
côtières explose de ville étaient les
agences de location de meublés s'efforce
de les satisfaire
cette année c'est un peu différent pour
juin est les locations le nombre de
locations a été beaucoup moins important
pour mais n'en parlons pas bien sûr
puisque ne vont presque rien fait pour
juillet on peut considérer jusqu'à cette
date
kylie a au minimum 35 à 40% des
locations qui ne sont pas encore
réalisés et ce bien que bien que bien
que quelques propriétaires et comment
dirais-je et réduit un tout petit peu
leur prix quant au mois d'août je pense
que nous arriverons bien à faire aux
minimes à atteindre au minimum 95 % le
problème de l'hôtellerie de luxe est
plus grave la clientèle et futurs de
plus cette année allemands belges
hollandais renonce à la bretagne
lorsque les investissements financiers
sont importants et qu'arrivent les
désistements
il y à trois mètres en colère aussi
certains hôteliers refuse de rendre les
armes
et pourquoi les rendre et on les arts
vous ne rêvez pas et pourquoi les rendre
et on nous assurons les mêmes services
nous pratiquons les mêmes prix parce que
nous sommes sûrs de pouvoir offrir ce
que nous offrons les petits hôtels les
ponts sont soumis sont moins sensibles à
ce genre de situation pour l'été
l'araignée réservations sont tout à fait
normales une appli en thelle connaissant
bien la région s'est pas désisté
j'ai des clients fidèles depuis vingt
ans les aucun problème on comprenait la
vie reprend bretagne même à portsall
comme avant on cueille legault et vous
meurtri handicapés les bretons de la
côte sont confiants malgré tout un
symbole
ils repeignent la coque des navires la
marée noire ne reviendra plus ils ont
tout fait pour être prêt à l'heure c'est
une réussite à 90 % le reste le
peaufinage
c'est la nature qu'il fera le vent le
soleil l'oxygène et marées c'est une
affaire de quelques années avec alain
jérôme et joseph pasteur nous ferons de
portsall et de paris un point encore
plus complet tout de suite après journal
j'ai assez l'égard de livres a
recommandé le guide de la france polluer
chez fayolle qui traite de toutes les
sources de pollution dans l'hexagone et
puis ce petit recueil pratiques et
juridiques vacances sports loisirs tout
ce qu'il faut savoir avant de partir en
vacances
ouverture aujourd'hui d'un procès d'un
citoyen au dessus de tout soupçon du
moins jusqu'à il ya deux ans jusqu'à la
mort d'un journaliste à toulouse rené
trouver le citoyen bien comme il faut
est un notable de la ville le docteur
birague bernard marck et y assister à
son procès membres après deux ans et
quatre mois d'instruction la sphère
birague comme on dit à toulouse arrive
enfin devant les jurés de la haute
garonne dans un palais de justice envahi
par le public une heure avant
l'ouverture du procès
une affaire judiciaire hors du commun
qui a commencé le 19 février 1976 avec
l'assassinât d'un journaliste
indépendant correspondant local d'un
hebdomadaire parisien rené trouver
cinquante deux ans un homme au passé
trouble anciens waffen ss chroniqueur
obsédés des petits scandales toulousain
est tué d'une balle en pleine tête dans
le réduit à poubelles d'un immeuble des
quartiers chauds cinq mois plus tard le
tueur christian portet 28 ans est arrêté
à la frontière espagnole il s'est
dénoncé lui-même par une lettre adressée
au ministre de l'intérieur
joseph picard son complice se présentent
spontanément à la police tous deux dans
une relation détaillée du crime et de sa
préparation ils ont agi distille sur
l'ordre du docteur claude birague un
notable très en vue ancien du rpf agent
électoral actifs et puissant saisie sur
le tard par l'ambition politique à
toulouse son arrestation le voici fait
l'effet d'une bombe
l'acte d'accusation a révélé cet après
midi que l' enquête a réuni un faisceau
de présomptions graves qui confirme la
dénonciation des deux tueurs comme
mobile l'accusation retient une
tentative de chantage à l'encontre du
docteur birague mise en cause dans les
articles de rené trouver et menacées de
l'être à nouveau
le docteur consul de monaco et président
des cdr comité de défense de la
république à toulouse riche et la tête
enflée par et autres relations
politiques auraient décidé de supprimer
le gnr il est accusé de complicité
d'assassinât et risque donc une peine
égale à celle du meurtrier
mais il n'a jamais avoué être
l'instigateur du crime on espère que les
débats prévus pour durer quatre jours
apporteront sur cette affaire assez de
lumière pour lever tous les doutes
cordes des ordinations dans le séminaire
traditionaliste d'ecône 16 prêtres et 21
soudiac ont été ou seront ordonnés
pardon après demain jeudi par
monseigneur lefebvre
mais cela n'est pas ce qui inquiète le
plus lés guise aujourd'hui ce qui
l'inquiète c'est la baisse considérable
depuis dix ans des ordinations nous
sommes en ce moment dans la peine
période où elle se pratique trop quatre
jours et les chiffres sont
impressionnants 40 % de moins qu'en 68
à cela de multiples raisons que nous ne
la verrons pas mais nous avons maintenu
l'une d'entre elles une certaine
rigidité peut-être du corps
ecclésiastique et c'est elle qui
explique en partie le départ de bon
nombre de prêtres de religieux et
religieuses
on en compte aujourd'hui quinze mille
qui aujourd'hui marié ou pas avoue avoir
du mal à se situer dans la société ou
dans l'église cela souffre d'un certain
mépris à leur endroit avoir été prêtres
aux religieux aujourd'hui en france et
ne plus l'être
et bien c'est toujours aussi mal jugé
cet homme aux cheveux grisonnants
gardien d'une usine dans une ville de
l'ouest était prêtre il ya trois ans
encore son univers d'alors c'était
l'église les cérémonies du culte ce
monde du prêtre tel qu'on le connaît
depuis toujours
à 52 ans celui que chacun appelait
monsieur le curé décide de rompre avec
son passé et quitte le sacerdoce
redevenu monsieur tout le monde il se
met à la recherche d'un travail
alors affluent les obstacles enquête
absence de carte de sécurité sociale est
très souvent refus d'emploi lorsqu'il
avoue la vérité tout au début c'est très
difficile de on se trouve vraiment comme
mis au ban de la société
mis au ban de sa famille parce que là
aussi la famille trouve que quelqu'un
qui a été dans le ministère et qui lâche
c'est vraiment envie nombreux alors on
est complètement coupée de tout le monde
jusqu'à présent je ne regrette rien je
suis heureux là où je suis vous n'avez
pas perdu la foi
avant je n'ai pas perdu la foi j'ai
gardé la foi totalement si j'ai quitté
d'ailleurs c'est pas à cause de ça c'est
pas une histoire de foi c'est plutôt
pour par charité pour aider quelqu'un et
puis parce que j'aimais cette personne
avec qui je vis maintenant
henry lui est parti à presque 60 ans
prêtre depuis plus de 35 ans il a
abandonné le sacerdoce à cause d'un
désaccord profond avec l'église et ses
modes d'agir aujourd'hui les malades
sans emploi sans ressources sans
retraite
mais malgré l'avenir angoissant si l'on
sent chez lui beaucoup de souffrances on
ne décèle aucun regret non je ne
regrette absolument rien
parce que au moment où j'ai quitté
l'église disons que je ne voulais pas
cautionner cette église auprès des gens
qui me faisait confiance
alors que moi j'avais perdu ma confiance
dans l'église et puis lors une autre
raison c'est que je me me voulait en
solidarité avec tous mes camarades qui
avaient quitté le ministère qui s'était
même mariés parce qu'il était considéré
par l'église par les responsables comme
des parias et je ne voyais pas du tout
en quoi ça pouvait s'accorder avec une
belle parabole comme celle du père de
l'enfant prodigue
et puis même latitude et surtout
l'attitude de jésus-christ vis-à-vis des
femmes adultères il veut fait partie de
ces prêtres jeunes qui ont réussi
relativement bien se refaire une
existence connus et acceptés dans son
milieu de travail il est marié avec une
jeune femme qu'il avait rencontrée dans
sa paroisse pourquoi votre avis y at-il
autant de prêtres comme vous aujourd'hui
qui équipe le ministère il y de l'église
il me semble que c'est le grand décalage
qui existe entre la structure de
l'église et le monde avec ce que le
monde cherche c'est dont il a besoin
l'église ne semble pas répondre et sa
structure semble éloigné de ce que le
monde recherche mari joue la femme de
yves étaient divorcés lorsqu'elle a
épousé quand son entourage a su qu'elle
allait désormais vivre avec un ancien
prêtre les réactions étaient souvent dur
et sans concession on n'a pas dit par
exemple que les mariages les prêtres
sont vouées à l'échec
on m'a dit oui quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup a dit que je ne serai jamais
l'heureuse parce que justement après
qu'on peut préparer à faire un père de
famille un écho 1 et que ça pourrait
jamais collé et puis 1 50
j'écoute très bien j'ai l'impression de
former tous les deux un couple comme les
autres oui je ne pouvons pas la question
quelques succès mais trop fréquemment
des difficultés insurmontables la
situation humaine affective et
matérielle des prêtres qui quittent
l'église les a conduits sur l'initiative
de l'un d'entre eux à se regrouper en
associations correspond exactement à ce
que nous avons entrepris depuis un an
c'est à dire de donner quelque chose à
ceux qui n'ont pas et n'ont pas de
donner à ceux qui ont déjà en fait ça
correspond exactement à nos perspectives
obtenir pour tous des conditions
décentes d'avenir mais surtout informer
tel est l'objectif de repères et de ses
amis veut pas vivre honteux parce qu'on
a été 15 ans 20 ans prête on a quand
même donné 15 ans 20 ans de sa vie pour
les autres et pour l'église et je ne
vois pas pourquoi nos familles seraient
honteuse parce qu'on a quitté le
ministère
l enseignant donné un fils une fille à
l'église les gens sont partis l'église
doit s'interroger en avis sur le
l'hémorragie qui a eu lieu parce qu'elle
à quoi elles concernent l'église façon
importante et en changeant de l'avenir
sont l'avenir et les raisons du côté de
ceux et celles qui sont parties sont des
raisons personnelles si vous voulez moi
ça m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que les gens
ces hommes et ces femmes là puisse
repartir dans la vie et ils revivent
c'est ça qui est important
question grave qui concerne en france
quinze mille anciens prêtres frère et
religieuse face à eux l'église mal à
l'aise jours at elle seulement la carte
de la justice ou acceptera-t-elle de
regarder avec compréhension
ceux qui restent entre eux mêmes disent
n'avoir voulu changer que deux visages
voilà avec nous monseigneur badr est
qu'ils aient vent que représentants de
la hiérarchie catholique c'est à dire de
l'épiscopat et qui va donc répondent
d'abord aux deux premières questions que
pose ce reportage la question qu'on pose
un prêtre et qui dit l'église va-t-elle
s'interroger sur son hémorragie
puis la question de jean claude
d'arrivée
l'église va t'elle plus compréhensives à
l'égard de ses anciens prêtres lance
d'abord l'hémorragie l'hémorragie je
pense que le mot est peut-être un petit
peu fort
quinze mille vous avez dit six mille
prêtres 10000 religieuses et religieux
c'est important c'est vrai mais cela
représente quand même par rapport à
100000 religieuse à 34 mille prêtres
un chiffre important je dis bien mais ce
n'est quand même pas une hémorragie et
je crois que c'est la première chose
qu'il faut dire ceci étant a affirmé je
crois que l'église ne peut pas
considérer sans tristesse ces hommes qui
ont donné leur vie au christ et qui
continue à vouloir la lui donner et qui
cependant se trouve comme des exclus
comme des parias c'est ce qu'ils disent
je pense que c'est cela qui nous
interroge beaucoup plus que le fait même
de l'hémorragie ou du départ il se sent
projetée par vous même alors ils se
sentent rejetés par la communauté
chrétienne plus que par douch crois je
peux vous donner un témoignage personnel
j'ai dans mon diocèse de nombreux
prêtres mariés et veut les connais tous
ou presque tous
je les ai presque tous vu et je pense
que je les ai aidés à trouver une
nouvelle place à la fois dans l'église
et dans la société et je pense que c'est
très important cela
par contre la communauté des chrétiens a
plus de mal à comprendre ce qu'ils font
parce que à juste titre le chrétien voit
dans le prêtre non pas simplement celui
qui est un ministère un service dans la
communauté
mais celui qui a donné sa vie à dieu
celui qui est un homme consacré celui
qui est un homme qui a accepté d'être le
serviteur de dieu et le serviteur des
mystères de dieu je crois que ces cinq
étapes
est-ce que vous pensez que l'église
d'une manière globale va changer quand
même d'attitude parce que à certains
d'entre eux par exemple 10 j'aimerais
bien reprendre du ministère j'aimerais
bien ne pas être considéré comme un
marginal parce que vous dites que pour
vous ils ne sont pas des marginaux et
pour les paroisses où les communautés
chrétiennes c'est moins net
je pense que l'église ne changera pas
d'attitude sur le fond en ce sens que il
y a eu vraiment de leur ordination une
sorte de contrat en disant que pour
accès pour être ordonnées pour accéder
au ministère sacerdotal et accepter le
célibat il ya eu un moment où ce contrat
a été co
le célibat ils l'ont refusé l église a
accepté qu'il le refuse
alors à ce moment-là elle les considère
comme des laïcs s'élève l'expression je
n'aime pas beaucoup réduction à l'état
laïque parce que ce n'est pas une
expression qui est très sympathique mais
elle considère comme des chrétiens
engagés et ils peuvent faire tout ce que
fait un chrétien baptisé confirmés ils
peuvent faire le catéchisme et cetera
famille si vos voisins protestants on
connaît des pasteurs marié pourquoi pas
des prêtres mariés
je sais pas c'est une vieille discipline
de l'église
voyez vous je crois que peut-être qu'un
jour l'église ordonnera des hommes
mariés ça c'est un autre problème
mais à partir du moment où à
l'ordination quelqu'un accepter cette
loi du celib elle a accepté librement
doit plus on en dise je pense que il est
normal que s'il n'accepte plus
eh bien il se retrouve dans une autre
situation alors ceux qui espèrent
retrouver un ministère c'est sans espoir
à votre avis je crois que c'est sans
espoir aux fault honnête là dessus je
crois que c'est sans espoir parce qu'il
ya eu comme une rupture de contrat si
vous voulez jeter une rupture de contrat
c'est comme un divorce d'une certaine
façon avec l'église si vous voulez je
crois que c'est ça enseignant la région
merci demain et nous changeons
complètement le sujet vous allez le voir
demain pour caroline de monaco jour j
jour j comme juno juno philippe devant
un parterre de rois de stars de
personnalités et dans une principauté de
monaco partagé entre l'attendrissement
et l'effervescence le mariage de l'année
en effet les festivités commencent ce
soir avec le bal au palais offert par le
prince rainier par la princesse grace de
mettre célébrer le mariage civil et
jeudi
la cérémonie religieuse me fais
l'interprète de toute la rédaction
d'antenne 2 pour présenter toulouse de
bonheur pour vos futures étoiles à
wimbledon maintenant qualification du
français
de bleeckere pour le deuxième tour il a
éliminé le hollandais sanders en cinq
manches quand à villa sylviane triompher
l'américain stan smith en trois sets
secs
voilà le temps pour terminer dernière
page de ce journal
aujourd'hui s'il était dominée par des
pluies le matin suivi d'éclaircies vous
allez voir ça derrière moi l'après midi
températures toujours aussi fraîche
demain ne sera pas toujours une journée
d'été ciel couvert
et très nuageux de la manche au nord et
au nord-est ailleurs alternance de
périodes ensoleillées et zone nuageuse
très légère baisse des températures
dernier journal après les dossiers de
l'écran je voulais 10 vers 23h30 pour
vous présenter
gérard holtz vous remercie de votre
attention je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
bonsoir à tous ça demain
à